[Musique]
Justin Trudeau aime se présenter comme
un geek
capable d'expliquer les bases de la
physique quantique
devant les vedette scientifique
[Musique]
son gouvernement promettait d'injecter
un nouvel enthousiasme pour la science
mais dans les laboratoires et les chers
de recherche au pays les francophones
vivent un mélange de crainte et de
frustration la recherche qui se fait en
français diminue c'est plus facile de
faire financer de la recherche en
anglais qu'en français il y a lieu de
sonner l'alarme
selon les données obtenues par
Radio-Canada la science en français est
en perte de vitesse au pays depuis 30
ans je vois une certaine tendance à des
demandes qui sont soumises en anglais il
y a une inquiétude il y a un doute chez
les chercheurs francophones par rapport
à
quels sont mes chances d'obtenir une
subvention une tendance qui touche la
plupart des domaines et surtout la santé
où les demandes de subvention en
français sont plus souvent rejetés
de 2000 heures à 2016 39% des demandes
de subvention en anglais ont été
acceptées ces 29% pour les demandes en
français je ne prendrai pas de chance je
vais la soumettre en anglais ce qui est
malheureux mais ce qui en même temps je
dirais une sorte de mécanisme de défense
voire de survie pour les francophones
c'est beaucoup plus un choix stratégique
qu'un choix spontané
chez les chercheurs francophones ont
sont donc une certaine résignation
de publier ou de développer les projets
de les soumettre aux organes
subventionnaires en anglais pour assurer
des plus grandes chances d'être
financier
il serait donc plus payant de faire de
la science en anglais au cours des trois
dernières années les projets de
recherche en anglais ont reçu 8
milliards de dollars en subventions soit
95% des sommes accordées la recherche en
français et elle n'a reçu que des
miettes ce qui préoccupe la directrice
générale de la face pour la première
fois on a eu des chiffres claires soit
bas et excessivement alarmant des
chiffres qui attestent un
[Musique]
là déclin mais irrémédiable en quelque
sorte d'éclin de la recherche en
français une disparité dans le
financement qui décourage les chercheurs
francophones on décide de soumettre nos
demandes de subvention en anglais pour
augmenter nos chances de financement
résultat le français dégringole dans les
demandes de financement présentés aux
organismes fédéraux
au début des années 2000 la moitié des
demandes de subventions étaient faites
en français et sur 20 ans le déclin est
constant maintenant moins du tiers des
demandes sont présentées en français
c'est quand même exigeant comme projet
pour les chercheurs la valeur de
l'anglais ne se calcule pas seulement en
dollars on essaie d'avoir une portée un
peu plus internationale et aussi parce
que la recherche en anglais publie en
anglais de manière générale beaucoup
plus valorisée
[Musique]
les demandes de subvention qui chutent
des projets acceptés au compte-goutte un
financement famélique selon certains la
science en français au pays s'évapore
les constats sont alarmes ça sème
beaucoup de chez moi nous dirigeons
complètement vers l'agonie le Bloc
québécois estime que les chercheurs
francophones sont pénalisés est-ce que
le gouvernement fédéral juge important
qu'une de ces deux langues officielles
soit représentatives dans la dans le
monde scientifique
il est complètement silencieux absent
manque de vision complète pour le
soutien du français anciences
[Musique]
8 millions de dollars sur cinq ans afin
de soutenir la recherche en français
c'est urgent qu'on a une stratégie
nationale pour appuyer la recherche en
français parce que sinon les chercheurs
angloph les chercheurs francophones
perdant vont finir par édifier
complètement
pour les chercheurs ce n'est qu'une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan un début de
solution
[Musique]